>>> WELCOME BACK TO "STATE OF
THE UNION."
M DANA BASH.
LAST WEEK HOUSE REPUBLICANS
VOTED OUT EIR NUMBER THREE
LEAD, LIZ CHENEY, FOR TELLING
THE TRUTH ABT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THE JANUAR6th
CAPITOL ATTACKS.
THIS WEEK HOUSE REPUBLICANS WILL
TAKE ANOTHER VOTE ON A
BIPARTISAN DEAL TO FORM A
COMMISSION TO EXAMINE THOSE
ATTACKS, EVEN AS SEVERAL HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO
REWRITE HISTORY ABOUT THAT
TERRIBLE DAY.
MY NEXT GUEST WAS AT THE CAPITOL
DURING THE ATTACKS OF JANUARY
6th AND VOTED TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER IT.
JOINING ME NOW IS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN FRED UPTON OF
MICHIGAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
ME, CONGRESSMAN.
SO YOUR COLLEAGUES WORKING TO
FORM A JANUARY 6th COMMISSION
SAID THEY STRUCK A BIPARTISAN
DEAL.
G.O.P. LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
SAYS HE IS STILL LOOKING INTO
IT.
DO YOU FOR THE PROPOSAL, AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE McCARTHY
SUPPORTED?
>> ABSOLUTELY I SUPPORT IT.
JOHN KATKO HAS DONE A REMARKABLE
JOB AS THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE.
HE IS A MEMBER OF THE PROBLEM
SOLVERS CAUCUS, OF WHICH I AM A
VICE-CHAIR, AND HE HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD THE LAST
NUMBER OF WEEKS, LIKE FIVE TO
SIX WEEKS, ON TRYING TO CRAFT A
DEAL THAT REALLY DOES MAKE
SENSE, THAT WE'LL BRING
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT TO IT.
YOU REMEMBER THAT INITIALLY
SPEAKER PELOSI SAID THAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE A PARTISAN
COMMISSION.
IT WAS GOING TO BE SEVEN
DEMOCRATS, FOUR REPUBLICANS,
VIRTUALLY ALL OF US BALKED AT
THAT, SAID THAT'S NOT REALLY
FEAR.
SO THE DEMOCRATS MOVED.
I TALKED TO THE -- HOYER AND
OTHERS.
THIS IS AN EQUALSUBPINA POWER.
IT HAPPENS TO BE DONE BEFORE THE
END OF THE YEAR.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE CURRENT
SITTING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
FAIR.
IT SHOULD GET A GOOD NUMBER OF
VOTES.
YES, I HOPE KEVIN McCARTHY
SUPPORTS IT.
>> LEADER McCARTHY SPOKE TO
THEN-PRESIDENT TRUMP ON JANUARY
6th AS THE RIOTERS WERE INSIDE
THE CAPITOL.
LIZ CHENEY SAID HE SHOULD
TESTIFY BEFORE THE COMMISSION.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> YEAH, MY SENSE IS THAT THAT
BODY, THE TEN PEOPLE THAT ARE
THERE, ARE GOING TO SUBPINA A
NUMBER OF FOLKS.
I SUSPECT -- I AM NOT A LAWYER.
WHETHER THEY WERE BARRICADING
THE DOORS INSIDE THE CHAMBER.
I WASN'T ACTUALLY IN THE CHAMBER
WHEN IT HAPPENED, BUT I WAS,
OBVIOUSLY, ON CAPITOL HILL.
I HAVE SOME BROKEN GLASS, IN
FACT, THAT I PICKED UP WHEN WE
RETURNED FROM VOTES -- FOR VOTES
THAT NIGHT.
BUT, YEAH, THEY ARE GOING
SUBPOENA A NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET THE TRUTH
AND FIND OUT HOW WIDESPREAD THIS
THING WAS AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MAKE SURE IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
>> SPEAKING OF THE TRUTH, SOME
OF YOUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
ARE TRYING TO REWRITE HISTORY
ABOUT THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION.
LISTEN TO WHAT SOME OF THEM SAID
THIS WEEK.
>> THE D.O.J. IS HARESING
PEACEFUL PATRIOTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> IT WAS TRUMP SUPPORTERS WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES THAT DAY.
NOT TRUMP SUPPORTERS WHO WERE
TAKING THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
>> IT WAS NOT AN INSURRECTION.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW THE
FOOTAGE WAS A VIDEO FROM JANUARY
6th, YOU WOULD ACTUALLY THINK IT
WAS A NORMAL TOURIST VISIT.
>> CONGRESSMAN UPTON, WHAT IS
YOUR RESPONSE TO THOSE
STATEMENTS FROM YOUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES?
>> BOGUS.
ABSOLUTELY BOGUS.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY BOGUS.
I WAS THERE.
I WATCHED A NUMBER OF THE FOLKS
WALK DOWN TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THEN BACK.
I HAVE A BALCONY ON MY OFFICE.
SO I SAW THEM GO DOWN.
I HEARD THE NOISE.
THE FLASH-BANGS, I SMELLED SOME
OF THE GAS AS IT MOVED MY WAY.
OBVIOUSLY, I WAS WATCHING LIVE,
THE LIVE VIDEO THAT WAS WAS
CARRIED ON OUT THE NETWORKS AT
THE TIME.
I TALKED TO A NUMBER OF S.W.A.T.
TEAM MEMBERS, TALKED TO SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO WERE IN THE
CHAMBER AND SPENT TIME WITH
OFFICER FANONE, THE METROPOLITAN
POLICE OFFICER WHOSE BODY CAM
WAS, YOU ALL AIRED IT EARLIER
THIS WEEK, BUT IT'S BEEN WIDELY
NOW AVAILABLE.
I SAW FIRSTHAND WHAT THAT WAS
AND IT DID NOT CHANGE MY OPINION
FROM WHAT I PERSONALLY SAW ON
JANUARY 6th.
>> DOES IT MAKE YOU ANGRY --
>> IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
THIS -- WELL, I JUST -- YOU
KNOW, SOMEONE SAID EARLIER THIS
WEEK THAT, YOU KNOW, ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES SAID SOME OF THOSE
THINGS WAS ACTUALLY WAS IN THE
CHAMBER, HEARING THE NOISE,
HEARD THE SHOTS.
>> WHAT ARE THEY DOING --
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I COULD
BE --
>> WHAT ARE THEY DOING HERE?
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
>> THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
MOTIVATION IS.
BUT I KNOW THAT, AS I TALK TO
SOME COLLEAGUES EVEN AGAIN THIS
BEAK WHO WERE IN THE CHAMBER, IT
WAS TERRIBLY FRIGHTENING.
IT WAS -- THEY -- AND THEY KNEW
THAT BY STOPPING SOME OF THOSE
FOLKS FROM GETTING INSIDE TO THE
HOUSE CHAMBER, IT PROBABLY SAVED
THEIR LIVES.
YOU KNOW, I SAW THE GALLOWS THAT
WERE CONSTRUCTED ON THE EAST
FONT OF THE CAPITOL.
I HAVE TALKED -- ONE OF THE
POLICE OFFICERS, CAPITOL HILL
POLICE OFFICERS IS FROM MY
HOMETOWN.
SPENT SOME TIME WITH HIM.
IT WAS CHILLING WHAT HAPPENED.
ABSOLUTELY CHILLING.
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS BIPARTISAN COMMISSION,
GET THE FACTS OUT, TRY TO ASSURE
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENED, AND LET THE FACTS LEAD
US TO THE CONCLUSION.
>> LET'S TALK MORE BROADLY ABOUT
THE STATE OF YOUR PARTY.
YOUR FRIEND AND COLLEAGUES LIZ
CHENEY, OF COURSE, WAS REPLACED
WITH ELISE STEFANIK AS
CONFERENCE CHAIR THIS WEEK.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO WHAT
CONGRESSWOMAN CHENEY HAD TO SAY
RIGHT AFTER SHE WAS VOTED OUT.
>> WE MUST GO FORWARD BASED ON
TRUTH.
WE CANNOT BOTH EMBRACE THE BIG
LIE AND EMBRACE THE
CONSTITUTION.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
ENSURE THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
NEVER AGAIN GETS ANYWHERE NEAR
THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> CONGRESSMAN UPTON, YOU HAVE
BEEN A MEMBER MUCH CONGRESS
SINCE 1987.
YOU HAVE SEEN A LOT OF UPS AND
TOWNS.
YOU ARE ONE OF TEN REPUBLICANS
WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF YOUR PARTY AND, MORE
BROADLY, DEMOCRACY?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
WE ONLY WIN BY ADDITION, NOT
SUBTRACTION.
I WAS A SUPPORTER OF LIZ.
I HAVE GOTTEN TO KNOW HER OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS FOR
SURE.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO WIN
ELECTIONS UNLESS YOU HAVE THAT
BIG TENT.
SO I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED ABOUT
WHAT WE DID.
SHE ACCEPTED THAT IT SHOULD GO
BY A VOICE VOTE EARLIER IT WEEK.
SO THAT'S THE WAY THAT IT
HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW, IT'S THE PRESIDENT,
FORMER PRESIDENT, THAT
CONTINUES, AND EVEN YESTERDAY
ABOUT THE BIG LIE, ABOUT THE
ELECTION BEING STOLEN.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO WIN UNLESS
WE ARE A BIG TENT.
AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO WIN
UNLESS WE ADD TO OUR BASE, NOT
SUBTRACT FROM IT.
>> DOES IT --
>> CERTAINLY IN '24.
>> DOES IT SKERN YOU YOUR OWN
PARTY LEADERSHIP NOW TO A PERSON
SUBSCRIBES TO A FORMER PRESIDENT
WHO, IN YOUR WORDS, IS STILL
PUSHING THE BIG LIE?
>> WELL, IT SORT OF IS WHAT IT
IS.
IT'S JUST THE WAY THAT IT IS.
WE ALL RUN OUR OWN RACES.
WE ALL HAVE OUR DISTRICT
OPERATIONS.
WE ALL -- FOR ME, YOU KNOW, I
HAVE NEVER BEEN AFRAID TO BE FOR
OR AGAINST A PARTICULAR
PRESIDENT REGARDLESS OF PARTY
AND TRYING TO GET THINGS DONE.
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN MY MISSION.
AND I KNOW THAT, AS YOU LOOK TO
THE FUTURE, WE HAVE TO HAVE
INDEPENDENT VOICES, PARTICULARLY
FROM PURPLE STATES OR DISTRICTS.
YOU CAN'T BE A RUBBER STAMP.
WHAT WORKS IN SOUTHWEST MICHIGAN
IS ENTIRELY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
HAPPENS IN, YOU KNOW, PLANO,
TEXAS.
>> CERTAINLY NOT EASY.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON AND I
APPRECIATE YOU SPEAKING THE
TRUTH.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THOSE